[Musique]
soit
Nous voulons tous retourner en classe
compagnie de nos amis professeurs
et les professeurs nous manquent
Cependant, le risque pour la santé et
la vie est encore haute
la réalité
nous oblige à la patience et à la prudence
sinon ça peut nous arriver comme
israël corée du sud royaume uni france
pour citer quelques exemples qui ont ouvert
leurs écoles et ont dû retourner à
fermer
[Musique]
via notre chaîne 7.3, nous allons
apporter l'éducation publique à tous
Mexique et pouvoir ainsi démarrer cette
nouvelle année scolaire
avec ce signe, nous approuvons notre
l'engagement du mexique ne sont pas les
conditions dans lesquelles nous nous attendions
retourner à l'école mais tu dois
continuer la vie continue pour ça
grand effort que la télévision fera
public et privé au Mexique est si
important
[Musique]